hey everybody what's up its chase
welcome to another episode of the show
chase charmers live show here on
creativeLIVE and you know this show this
is where I sit down with amazing humans
and I do everything I can to unpack
their brains with the goal of helping
you in your hobby career and/or life my
guest today is many things an
ultra-marathoner
an endurance athlete and number-one New
York Times best seller and the host of
one of the top podcasts out there in the
world called the rich roll podcast my
guess is no longer a secret
it's ritual in the house welcome to the
show but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so good to be here man
thank you you are like the og in the
space yes I mean I don't know when you
started your stuff but it was a long
time ago and I've been a subscriber to
your newsletter and a watcher of your
everything you've put out for like I
don't even remember when it didn't exist
so yes you know as somebody who now kind
of travels you know in a similar yea
space that you do I just want to thank
you Oh
for being an inspiration and setting an
example for like high quality content
yeah yeah so no I'm really happy to be
here and it's super cool to finally meet
you thanks and we were just talking
before the camera starts rolling about
we're planning for the the exchange of
ideas and well I will be on the rich
roll podcast and we're scheming it's a
super treat to have you on the show and
I also have noticed your hard work from
afar starting one of the first things I
realized was when you ran five five iron
man's or you did because it's more than
running it's biking swimming five in was
it five or seven days or something like
that in Hawaii on all the different
islands I did this thing this is
freakish by the way yeah this is know is
like this it was a while ago I was in
2010 so the story is my buddy Jason
Lester who's an incredible endurance
athlete and inspirational figure a
training partner of mine from many an
Ultraman competition I would do these
double Ironman competitions he came up
with this harebrained scheme this idea
to try to complete five Iron Man's on
five Hawaiian Islands in five days
literally an Ironman a day traveling
island island I'll help people who don't
know what an iron so actually is yeah
for those that don't know an Ironman
a very long triathlon widely considered
the ultimate test of human endurance
we're in over the course of one day you
swim 2.4 miles you ride your bike 112
miles and then you celebrate that by
running a marathon all it wants super
difficult and hard and you wanted a
stack flash face it's decided we should
do five of those in a row and in between
get on airplanes and try to schlep our
gear from island to island island so we
took a stab at it in 2010 on May 5th I
might add so it was 5:00 5:00 on a day
that we started it we ran into all kinds
of crazy logistical problems it was
quite the you know in certain respects
at debacle but also an amazing challenge
and adventure so it took us a little bit
longer than five days but we got it done
it was crazy making it sound like it was
two years but it was actually like seven
days or it was like six and a half days
yeah I mean we were like losing bike
parts like we had some people some some
beautiful people who volunteered to help
us yeah but we didn't have a whole crew
situation dollar we didn't know we were
doing we're like I have it's like crazy
thing was that the logistics were just
as challenging it was almost a relief to
just be out on your bike doing it
because we knew we have to finish by
this time because the last plane leaves
the island and we have to get on that
and we have to bring all our gear and
then we would get to the next island and
have to get to our hotel and by the time
we like ate and like took a shower it
was like the middle of the night and we
had two or three hours of sleep so the
sleep deprivation started to catch up to
us and we're I mean it was bananas the
whole thing that I remember that being
widely reported and like yeah oh my god
who is this guy yeah right I gotta meet
this character man so here we are
whatever years later well hey thanks for
starting off with the kind words around
content you have been putting out a ton
high-quality content as well the areas
of focus that I want to talk about today
that you know it's my goal to assemble
world-class performers from a whole
bunch of disciplines and you have both
you know achieved an amazing amazing
physical feats
you've also built a really interesting
business but mostly your ideas around
what's possible see the story we just
talked about plant-based diet something
I'm fascinated by the the storytelling
of your book and I think you have two
books right you have a cookbook that you
did with your wife is that right sort of
a plan we've got yeah I wrote a memoir
called finding ultra and then we have
three cookbooks actually three cool not
being an only plant-based eater I have
not my confession here for you is that I
have not consumed the cookbooks but
finding ultra is an amazing narrative of
your life and it's not it's not just
about you know plant-based diet it's
about your life and then so I'd like to
start let's go back in time we can
you're an endurance athlete what made
you want to be that what part of you
this is a strange part of the human
brain yeah that clicks into saying I
want to run you know a marathon plus 120
mile or plus a marathon bike 140 miles
and run swim two and a half that's nuts
and you've done cruel stuff too by the
way but yeah I've done a bunch of stuff
I mean I I look at it all you know not
to put too low of a point on it but for
me it's like all a spiritual journey of
personal growth and these crazy
endurance races are like a vehicle for
self-discovery in the same way that an
artist might find that you know you know
in a photograph or in pursuing a
photograph or a painting or making a
film the medium for me is is the outer
limits of what my body is capable of and
I think it was originally inspired by a
couple things first of all I was
somewhere in college so I had a
background as an athlete I swam at
Stanford in the late 1980s we want to
end situate Championships when I was
there I was a benchwarmer I wasn't I
know means you know a big point scorer
or a star on that team but I competed as
an athlete at a very high level
drugs and alcohol destroyed that career
and it really you know cut the head off
me achieving my potential as an athlete
so I feel like later in life I still had
unfinished business that I wanted to you
know pursue to see what I would be
capable of and also you know athletics
aside when I hit you know around 40 41 I
was having a little bit of an
existential crisis about what I was
doing with my life there's a longer
story baked into that but basically I've
been pursuing this career in law I was
on the partnership track at a big
prestigious law firm until I Cornell I
went to law Cornell you know in the wake
of problems with drugs and alcohol I got
sober at 31 and then spent the next nine
years trying to repair all the wreckage
that I'd created as a result of my
drinking and using was successful in
that regard and was very much blindly
you know just looking at that
traditional equation of success you know
partnership car house like you know
brass ring the whole like traditional
notion of what it means to be a
successful male in America
yeah and played that out to the point
where I realized that there was some
emptiness in that and had this confused
state about what I was doing with myself
because I wasn't doing it out of a
passion for the law or any of that I was
doing it to prove to myself and to
others that I could be a responsible
respectful person after being such a
train wreck for so many years and I
think trying to process what that meant
for myself created this this sense of
confusion and I found myself back into
fitness as a way of spending time alone
to process all of this to try to find a
way for
there was never some conscious decision
that I was going to become this
competitive athlete in my 40s and go
back and revisit unfinished business
it was really an organic outgrowth out
of trying to out of wrestling with and
trying to answer these questions for
myself about what I was going to do with
my life now wood is there a relationship
between your addiction to drugs and
alcohol and your passion would you call
it an addiction to exercise was it we
trading one thing for a destructive
thing for a healthy thing or was there a
reconciliation process because you know
I think trauma and we all have trauma in
life and we all express it in different
ways and I'm just curious how you are
you thought yeah I think it's a little
bit of both what you find in the
ultra-endurance community is a lot of
people who are in recovery from some
form of you know abuse or or or
substance addiction and I think it would
be intellectually dishonest to say no
you know I was addicted to drugs an
uncle but my relationship with these
doing these crazy things is completely
healthy you know of course there's some
compulsive aspect to that yeah but I
found my healthier self through those
pursuits like for me taking the drink
was always the easy way out
and getting up in the morning to put
your running shoes on or staring down
the barrel of some crazy difficult
workout that's a harder choice you know
that requires a little bit of backbone
and character so for me it's been a
learning experience and it's been a
positive thing but I do have to keep
those tendencies in check you know I'm
married I've got four kids like
let's left unchecked like I'll move into
a hut and just train all day and just
think about myself like I'm naturally
you know a a selfish self seeking person
and recovery for me is about you know
balancing that out against
you know everything else in my life
that's truly important so the pendulum
is always swinging and I always have to
kind of be doing an inventory about how
I'm relating to the world and is that in
a healthy healthy way or isn't that in a
very unhealthy or compulsive way I love
that you said unfinished business I
think that was it's a beautiful
descriptor and do you feel that you've
you know been able to redeem some of
that business that was that was undone
certainly I mean now I look back on it
and the idea that I needed to redeem
anything is sort of silly you know but
certainly I have done that I mean I've
been more successful and more you know
lauded for things I've done athletically
than I than I ever was but I was truly
at my athletic peak yeah so that's been
fascinating and unexpected and and
completely bizarre like I got into these
events like I said as a sort of
spiritual Odyssey to learn more about
what made me tick the fact that anybody
else would care about that other than
maybe my wife you know has been a
strange journey and a story I'm happy to
now tell but one that was not intended
and very much unexpected well let's keep
telling you so you there's this desire
to pursue some spiritual awakening 40s
you can call it a midlife crisis why I
want to pull on this is it's not not a
surprise here that a lot of people who
have pursued a path often the path
whether it was law or medicine or you
know doing what your but your father or
mother did because it was easy there's a
lot of people who are listening and
watching right now who are playing this
out and saying oh my gosh this is me and
I'm in the middle of my life and
thinking what have I done I've been
living the dream than somebody else you
know had for me I'm pursuing somebody
else's script it's time I got to write
my own so share us share with us your
your aversion how do you how do you
reconcile those things and get started
with the next chapter I wish I could
give you the three bullet points you
know here's how I do it you know
for me it was a long drawn-out painful
experience and like I said you know
getting out on my bike or getting out on
the trail to run or jumping in the pool
or the ocean were almost ways of of
connecting with myself the in the best
way that I could like that that that
time alone like I wasn't at the time an
active meditator and I wouldn't say that
those training sessions were meditation
proper but they were an active
meditation that allowed me to connect
with myself in a deeper way
in a way that I wasn't used to that
allowed me the space and the time and
the bandwidth to really sit with my
discontent and really ponder what a
future might look like and what I get to
do now was not the result of some grand
scheme that I concocted while out on the
bike it's really been an organic
outgrowth of me making it a fundamental
decision to just start doing what felt
right to me yeah to follow my instincts
in my intuition irrespective of whatever
the peanut gallery had to say about it
or what whether Society was gonna you
know launder me with social approval or
not to just say look I you know I don't
I don't care like I like I like what it
feels like to jump in the pool I like
what it with what it feels like to have
the Sun on my shoulder on a trail run at
dawn and I'm gonna just keep doing that
in a very childlike way like it's like
play you know and as we grow up we're
taught well this is things we don't do
anymore yeah yeah respectful a dollar or
not responses act like we're and I just
decided that I was gonna do it and I was
gonna listen to that music I was going
to entertain it not because I thought
that I would find some career path baked
into this but just because you know and
I think by continuing to double down on
that ultimately
the path has sort of been laid forward
in front of me brick by brick to figure
out what to do next but it's been very
difficult like financially incredibly
insecure we almost lost our house I've
had cars repossessed like it was not
this you know upward trajectory to you
know having this podcast and getting to
sit and talk to you today like there
were a lot of dark moments of the soul
and a lot of you know questioning
whether I was an insane person because
everyone around me was saying what are
you doing like you you could be
practicing why you'd be doing all these
things you could be making all this
money like what you're chasing this
crazy fool's errand you have kids you're
being irresponsible so it took a lot of
faith and and really conviction in order
to kind of stay true to the path was
that a muscle that you'd always had no
or was that a muscle that you had to
develop and if you had to develop it
what was your process definitely not a
muscle that I always had I wouldn't
consider myself an entrepreneur type
personality I was reared very much as a
safety seeker like just get into the
best school and like you know take that
path that well trodden path you know
that that is laid out for men you know
respectable men of your pedigree like I
grew up upper-middle class I went to
really nice schools I have parents that
took care of all of my needs that are
still together I wanted for nothing and
this was kind of the trajectory that all
my peers were on it never occurred to me
to veer off of that until I was really
like almost soul sick and felt like I
had no other choice but to do that so
for me it was very unfamiliar it was
almost like I had to shed a skin and
grow a new one and my process was hardly
methodical but I would say that my wife
really was my greatest teacher through
this process like she just had my back
even when things just look crazy she was
like and I was like I gotta go make some
money like the way that I know how does
she'd say no like you need to keep doing
what you're
we will figure this out but the path
forward and the way through all of these
difficulties is not to retreat and trace
your steps backwards but to continue to
blaze forward and I think without that
support in the home I don't know that I
would have been able to keep going so
you know do you think reconsider is she
important for you as the person that she
is
or is it important that when people are
trying to go in the same journey that
you've been through that there are
people that are in their corner mm-hmm
is that mentors is it a partners that
buddy is and yeah of course ideally it's
your spouse because it sounds like she's
she was you know it's very powerful
force for you but I'm thinking to
everyone that doesn't what's your wife's
name Julie okay to everybody who doesn't
have a Julie oh yeah
can you give it I think I think it's
super critical and important to find
like-minded souls who who support your
vision for yourself and hold that space
for your best self and believe in you I
think you need to balance that with
other people who can give you the hard
feedback about when you're going off
track or being a crazy person who can
give you the hard truth because
cheerleaders alone are not going to get
you there you need you need both you
know you need the tension between the
aspiration and the grounded reality in
order to find yourself and I think if
you I think we all need I think the word
mentor I find to be problematic because
there's a formality to it and everyone
you know chases the fancy name people I
want you to be my mentor I think
everybody has people in their community
who who
you know can be a source of of truth and
education don't you got yeah and those
people right you should find and seek
them out they're all around you you know
and if you can't find them in your
neighborhood you can find them online
and you can have a virtual relationship
with somebody but I think it's super
important to have a board of directors
you know I have people in my life as I'm
sure you do to that I call and rely upon
for every facet of like whether you know
marriage or parenting or profession you
know all of these things I think it's
important to surround yourself with
people who who are living the life that
you aspire to have in certain categories
and have an hour further down the path
in you you found both the tough love and
the cheerleader in Julie yeah I was like
tell me what are some of the things that
you heard from her that were surprising
you just shared one which is like it's
now it's not the time to retreat now
it's the time to go through right what
were some other was there some themes or
some commonalities that you were like
okay she's got my back this is what she
said this to me four or five times now
and I know fill in the black we were
just getting crushed financially I mean
it was looking back on it now it's
almost comical like we go because you
cut back on it exactly because we're on
the other side of it but like I said
like cars repossessed and and you know
we had our trash bins taken away I mean
really like embarrassing demoralizing
stuff and what Julie the what Julie
taught me through this whole process was
how to maintain your equanimity like
your she would say your job is to be
completely neutral like can you because
that is like the Jedi path right that is
like true power to be a warrior in the
eye of a storm like that yeah when
everything's coming at you and you feel
like life is out of control if you can
be neutral and maintain your integrity
your peace of mind
your equanimity that's like a superpower
so that was something that I observed in
her that I tried to hone within myself I
mean I remember when the repo guy came
to take my truck away and she came out
and greeted him in the driveway and she
said oh hey I'm Julie like would you
like some tea do you want to come in
like she was super nice and he was so
confused it's like wait a minute yeah I
know so yeah they're gonna murder me if
I go right with these people who are
these crazies the other thing is to
understand that that if you're being
visited with these kinds of dick
difficulties in your life to detach from
the notion that this is failure or a
referendum on who you are as a person
but rather to look upon it as an
opportunity this is your divine moment
we are here on earth to grow to expand
and these are lessons for us so our job
is to pay attention and to find the
nugget of wisdom within that and to grab
on to that and figure out the path
forward Wow yeah so I can't overstate
the the thread throughout you know the
hundreds of interviews that I've
personally done with you and folks like
you and and others that I've listened to
an ear show and others did that having
community of fear the average of the
five people you spend the most time with
you know have you looked around and
looked at who you're spending time I
think that is is such a common thread I
also will jump on the same bandwagon
like the whole mentor thing now you have
people asking me to be their mentor all
the time and it's just like sorry I
don't even know you but here's a
community and creating a community in a
community atmosphere where you can learn
you know the fact that that we're in a
world where this information is
available for free
hmm to me I think that's just I want to
restate that because I think you said it
much more eloquently than I did but it's
it's a really really powerful to have
they're not necessarily a person but
just a set of people that you are
inspired by that you respond to that you
want to emulate and the question I have
out of all this is if you're around
these people they're all have they'll
have their own identities and you're
learning from you know this person
online or this person in your life how
did you find the part of you in all of
that how did you how did you not just
become a reflection of Julie if she was
your rock in this time how did you find
you wow that's a that's a great question
that's a hard question it's my job I
mean I think I'm I think I'm still
trying to find that I don't know that I
have arrived in that place I don't know
if anybody truly arrives in that place
like if I had to say chase you know who
are you defined your so you're such a
great dick you have the show if you lip
it on you know uh let me try and answer
it actually no I want you to go first
and I will I will follow but you you
should try and answer it don't deflect
you go do you smell that is like yeah
there's like a bakery or something
if someone just kicked on D now these
sad cakes or the cinnamon bomb oh my
goodness if you're at home listening and
watching I'm so bummed you can't smell
how good it smells in this this
beautiful spot that we're doing here in
a Soto there was a defining moment for
me in this whole journey and it was
after I had done the five Ironman thing
and I was noticing that the media was
taking an interest in what I was doing
which as I mentioned earlier was kind of
a bizarre thing because I was just doing
this for myself
CNN Sanjay Gupta came to my house did
like a piece on me and and they asked
the people at CNN asked me to write a
guest blog post for cnn.com which I did
and it's a little like here's my story
and that got published and it was
tracking so well that they put it on the
CNN homepage and it became like the most
emailed story for 48 hours or 72 hours
something like that like it just hit a
nerve and it like track really well and
I just got shellacked with emails all of
a sudden I mean this was really like I
had never been like a public person in
any regard and some of these emails that
came in were just so touching and
unbelievable like I told my story in a
vulnerable way and it gave people
permission to then tell me their story
and I got these long you know multi
paragraph emails like this is what
happened to me and this is what I went
through and here's my struggles and my
pain and I was just so touched at the
feeling of trust that these people had
and I think it was very emotional for me
to like read all these emails and it
made me realize that the path forward
for me and where I can really serve is
to be a cipher for these people on the
path to transformation if I can be like
a home base or a safe place for the
to come to to confide in or to look to
for inspiration and guidance for what
the next step for them might be that
perhaps I had something to say in that
regard and so building upon that has
really been you know what I've done ever
since that the moment it's interesting
that there is there is a true north
inside of you you you you access that
through Varner ability right you wrote
your story out and people responded to
it and that gave you a feeling and it
was the feeling that you looked at like
wait a minute this is a sign yeah that
I'm doing the thing you talked to
earlier about intuition is that the same
feeling your this awareness that you had
once you'd put your you had to take the
first step obviously right CNN says you
want to write this you say not then you
might not have captured it but you did
and then you there was that response and
the response was just like oh my god hey
I'm not alone be I like this feeling
probably right maybe it sounds like
that's one of the things that clued you
off to like I can be a home but maybe I
can be a home base well I was very aware
that the vulnerability was the thing
that people were connecting with and
when I got the opportunity to write a
book I understood that that had to be
like the key sort of through line
throughout the entire narrative because
let's face it like I'm not I'm not like
it's not like I won some World
Championship like I've never won a race
like I've done some crazy things in
ultra endurance but there's plenty of
athletes out there they're a lot better
than me that are more talented than me
than are more that are more accomplished
than me so why am I giving it out why
about why am I being given an
opportunity to write a book like it's
weird right it doesn't on paper it
didn't really seem to make sense and so
I was very aware that the only reason
that people would would connect with my
story was going to be directly related
to the extent to which I was willing to
be vulnerable and talk about things that
you know aren't so comfortable and that
I'm not that proud of so the process of
writing it really was one
of just getting into the mindset of
private journaling like I had to I had
to make it like a diary that no one was
gonna read and then I would have these
moments where I can't like oh my god
there's gonna be a book like it I would
freak out and be paralyzed for you know
several days but in retrospect looking
back like I know that that's why the
book has been successful because it's
the humanity because everybody can find
some aspect of their own journey in you
know my pain points or my struggles and
you know my story isn't that remarkable
the things that I've gone through many
people have gone through far worse than
what I've had to endure to get to this
place but I think there's there's an
integrity in that honesty and I think
people respond to that and they know
when it's real do you think that that
true north of that beacon that thing
that's inside of in this case we're
talking about you that was inside of you
is that inside of everybody or is that
something you have to find is it
natively there do you have to create it
how do people understand their their
true north I don't know that there's
only one true north
maybe there's many for people but I
think the process of trying to unlock
that or discover that within oneself is
a journey of self-discovery that
requires rigorous self honesty and
rigorous adherence to one's personal
truth and I think a lot of people are
walking around not understanding what
that is for themselves like what do you
mean my personal truth like I'm just
going to work man I'm trying to like you
know make a buck yeah exactly
so in order to really connect with that
I think it's an inside job like you can
go out and ride your bike all day or or
you know do jiu-jitsu or lose a bunch of
weight but ultimately it's about your
relationship with you and that will be
revealed to you only in the in the
moments in which you are allowing
yourself to get quiet and
where you can shut off the thinking
Brainware you can become an observer of
your own thoughts and connect with your
own consciousness and in that
relationship as it develops through
meditation or mindfulness practice or
whatever strategy you employ I think
that your higher consciousness and what
it wants to be and then your job then
becomes piecing that together slowly
over a very long period of time for you
is that is that sound - - that's not
only is that not obtuse poetic it was
beautiful I'm kind of just like letting
it land there so for you was that the
trail was that that moment of quiet the
time the reflection was that the trail
and the ocean and the the path it was
all of those things and it was
meditation and it was connecting with my
body for the first time in a really long
time again it was about learning how to
connect with my instincts and then trust
them yeah and these are all things that
that I originally started to learn about
as a result of getting sober and being
in 12-step and understanding that you
know we're spiritual beings having a
human experience like these were all
crazy foreign concepts to me I had a
decade you know spent in church
basements and you know with fellow
alcoholics and drug addicts to acquaint
me with some of these concepts that I
then started to delt delve deeper into
and you know the physical you know
aspect of these things that I've done
are just one avenue of exploration for
that but I think there's many
you know it's different for for everyone
talked about meditation mindfulness
exercise a church basement any others
come to mind it can be your faith-based
community it can be your relationship
with your kids it can be sitting in a
cave it can be of a pass on a retreat it
can be you know like I just said
learning jujitsu it can be it can be
going out in nature and taking taking
photographs it could be what you do I
think it's about finding what lights
your own spark and then trusting your
instincts enough to pull on that thread
and continue to follow it with the
understanding that that more will be
revealed to you in time so it was it was
it a Rumi quote I don't remember we're
gonna botch this but it's a fair to say
I'm gonna try and summarize with someone
else's quote but you don't have to see
the whole staircase you just have to
find the first stair I think that's
super profound I think so many people
especially in this kind of self-help
rubric or universe that we're kind of
part of everybody wants to know all the
steps before they begin then they're
gonna decide there is a hmm
yeah we've has to get hard and I have to
sweat and cry right and bleed for this
I'm not sure I want it so can you show
me what looks like around the corner and
most people that are right already good
they're like sorry they're right that's
just you've got to take the first you
got to take the first step I mean use
use running as an example like well like
what watch do I need what shoes do I
need what I need my training plan is
that the right training plan or should I
do this training plan which race should
I sign up for its analysis paralysis
that keeps people stuck forever because
they want to understand the entire
journey from beginning to end yeah and
what they're failing to realize or
understand or embrace is that is that
the beauty of the whole experience is in
the unknowing that's where the faith
comes in you take that first step and
it's just fog in front of you you don't
know and you have to trust and you have
to be willing to take that leap of faith
into the
and believe that you will be caught that
you will be cradled somehow and that's
scary yes frightening you know it was
frightening for me but that's the Magic
Man you know and I don't want to deprive
somebody of that experience because
that's where all the beauty and the self
understanding and the faith and the
sense of self comes from you have four
kids mm-hmm how are you how or what are
you doing to imprint some of this just
gold into their lives there this is
parenting advice or it's just you know
the comment or sort of a trying to
understand humanity but are you well the
chances of them listening to this or low
don't trust me they're not gonna listen
they couldn't be less interested in
anything that I'm doing but what are
their ages so if you're so that so I've
got two boys that are my stepsons that
I've lived with since they were three
and four but they're now 22 and 23 and
they've moved out of the house they're
musicians and a band with my nephew
their cousin and they're working on
their first album so they're pursuing
their dream and they're incredibly
talented I have no doubt that they'll be
successful they're kind of embedded into
the music scene of East Los Angeles and
it's super cool to see them fully
engaged and what they want to be doing
with their lives then I've got two
daughters that are 15 and 11 15 year old
daughter
it's a tricky that's a tricky universe
and she's a visual artist and she goes
to an Arts High School in downtown Los
Angeles that's required our family to
kind of reconfigure how we live because
it's very far from our other house so my
wife and I are now splitting time
staying in an apartment that we rented
that's approximate to the school so that
we can be in full support of her dream
so
putting our money where our mouth is as
we were saying like you know before the
podcast started it was like whoa that I
was telling ya it's telling chase how
how I've spent half the week in downtown
LA which is where we're recording this
right now to be in support of our
daughter and I can't be somebody who who
is a public-facing individual telling
people to pursue what's in their heart
if I'm not actively engaged in
supporting my own daughter and doing
that so that's made our lives a little
bit complicated right now but it's been
cool and then our other daughters 11 and
she goes to school back near our other
house so life is you know not simple but
it's also beautiful and I can't say that
I have all the parenting answers I think
if there's one piece of parenting advice
that I would give that has been helpful
and has worked for us it's that we have
chosen to treat our kids like conscious
sentient individuals from a very young
age rather than talk down to them like
little kids to give them a sense of
sovereignty and respect at an early age
in an effort to urge them or prompt them
to develop their own personal sense of
self and and and self esteem at an early
age and I think that that has worked out
quite well so far agency agency correct
that's the word I was looking for yeah
it's just it's it's weird that that's
not a that's not a product that is
widely taught right you know the school
system if you look at the traditional
house it's quite the opposite I was
raising in middle lower middle class
family I didn't also want for much but I
also had like Nikes that had upside-down
Nike swoosh shoes and I didn't really
understand the difference until I did
one day I was like wait a minute how
come my Nikes are upside on my adidas
have more stripes but as far as the
basics I had them but the concept of age
and not my parent my parents are amazing
loving they're still together I was an
only child so I basically had the
attention of my parents but it wasn't
like I was oh hey man this is a thing
you have agency you can do whatever
they're very practical they're very
supportive until my mother wanted to do
but it's weird to me that we don't have
culturally embedded the idea of agency
and choice and autonomy and sovereignty
of some of the words that you used right
there what what are we doing wrong so
we're doing so many things wrong I mean
our whole education system needs to be
upended you know it was founded on these
you know in era of industrialization
ideas about how to create a healthy
worker for the system yeah and now we're
all carrying supercomputers around in
our pockets that can tell us the answer
to any question that we have and yet we
have an educational system that's
founded upon memorization and like rote
skills that I think the relevancy have
now been called into question and what
we need to do is teach children agency
teach them how to think for themselves
teach them how to be creative and their
problem-solving skills how to be team
members and team leaders like all of
these things that I think are essential
to being successful in our modern life
are just not even part of the
conversation when it comes to education
and I find that disheartening it puts
more pressure on the parents to instill
those things in the kids and kids that
have you know solid parents are gonna
get that but I think it should be the
responsibility of our educational system
to be teaching this the life skills that
I never learned when I was growing up
that's part of the reason they created
life exists because I didn't see that in
the world right can you imagine being
like 12 or 13 years old and being able
to open up a laptop and like learn about
the world with all this free content of
amazing wise people teaching you
whatever it is that you want to learn
like that was not available
and what is the impact of that on
culture and society and a young person's
mind is college relevant anymore for
certain people it is but I think for a
lot of people it isn't you know there
are so many new and innovative ways to
learn and I think we're becoming more
and more skill-based and a freelance
based economy and that's very different
from the traditional programming of the
typical university or collegiate
structure and yet those institutions
have yet to you know kind of mature to
what's actually happening right now sure
they're they're actually disincentivize
yeah they have billions of dollars with
a real estate they need you to
physically come and stand there and
there's sure this benefits for in-person
community of course IRL you know all
about it but not everything about all
the time yeah you're speaking my
language for sure I understand these
things that you know that systems based
on the factory which was a Prussian
system that was invented in the 1800s
and for moving people effectively
through a write a line and training
whether they're soldiers or the
Industrial Revolution you want to be a
factory its aim was produced widgets
that all look the same act the same and
go do a rote job 99% of those Whichard
don't exist anymore I all that all that
is so true you said something
interesting it's like the job of you
know you know a job of parents is to
teach their kids these things and I
think there's a lot of people just like
clicked for me well while you were
talking that it's not just the parents
and the kids because the people who are
listening to this most of them are the
adults mm-hmm and there's the same
mentality as present in what you use 41
right and so if if you're listening in
many this is resonating with you it's
not just about your 13 year old daughter
this is
could be about you as well you know and
I know we happily skirted my personal
story but I'm gonna bring it back here
as I did all of the same stuff you're
talking about the you know the the same
track that culturally approved go to
college I also was an athlete soccer
scholarship all the right things check
the boxes won you know got up high fives
from the right people and yet at you
know early 20s felt so lost so confused
and it was actually the deep shame that
I felt by letting down all of the people
in my life that had basically been
telling a lie to for years then and I
know I did not have a rough or a sad I
mean you know was fine but I was
definitely not doing my thing I was
doing somebody else's thing and it was
the shame and the guilt and the ultimate
overcoming of those things that as soon
as I had said hey you know what this old
like doctor thing I could give two shits
about being a donor in fact it sounds
terrible right I brought those volunteer
hours that I had to do to get into
Medical School
uh-huh they do those for a reason
because you need to really love it and I
hated it every second every second I was
at the hospital I hated it and the
moment that you decide to trust yourself
and follow your gut and your instincts
you're overwhelmed with guilt that
you're letting other people down for
sure you're not entitled to be able to
do that for yourself and I did a lot of
extra school outside of it I went to
graduate school and did a lot of things
that were dancing around the thing that
I knew is my truth and I was basically
juggling and hopping on one leg and
being a monkey for the other people in
my life who are lovely people beautiful
supportive I mean it's not like there
were no one was holding a gun to my head
known as saying but it was just like
culture and I'll also say it's right I'm
born white and born male yeah born in
America it's just straight us
acknowledge the privilege radical
privilege and so if I'm sitting here
like boo-hooing poor me how hard this
was to just finally realize I was living
someone else's lie and tell the people
that remember that money spent for me in
graduate school or whatever like that's
all wasted yeah because I never wanted
to do it from day one and I had to do it
to figure it out probably but like that
for every one of those aspects of me
there's more guilt and shame around and
you know I can imagine if I didn't have
both my parents or if I was you know
actually poor like and came from a you
know I wasn't white and male and you
know all these advantages like so I had
all kinds of guilt and stuff piled on to
that and I will when I'll confess here
is that it was in playing through that
just actually okay I just told my
parents I'm not gonna do that and I'm
I'm looking at my my student loan debt
and it's a sixty seven thousand dollars
mm-hmm
and you sit in that for a little bit
like you know what I can actually be
okay with this it wasn't like that
honest I don't want to go plate this
thing because it was a lot of pain but I
want to know a little bit about yours
that was mine how we did did you have to
sit you mentioned 10 years in church in
church basements was that the sitting
with the the fact that you disappointed
all those things that helped you find
your TrueNorth you talked about it being
on the trail you talked about not
knowing everything but knowing one thing
can you tell me what was like - yeah
it's been kind of up and down like this
I mean you know I grew up in a very
education focused household was
definitely a top priority
and I struggled academically for a long
time and then finally figured it out
when I was in high school and what was
it they figured out I figured out that
although I wasn't academically gifted I
realized that I had a capacity to to be
a workhorse and that's something that
I've used as well in the pool and in
sports that you know I'm not the
smartest I'm not the most gifted
athletically but I know how to [ __ ]
work and I know how to suffer and I'll
get it done
you know I cannot work that God next to
me and that that served me in the
classroom served me in swimming pool and
all these other areas of life and and I
was able to kind of stake my claim on
that character trait so by the time I
was graduating high school top student
my class I got into like every college I
applied to all the fancy schools and was
also a top Swimming recruit so I had my
pick and I went to Stanford which was
like number one school number one
swimming program like the world was my
oyster like it was just this clear skies
ahead upward upwardly mobile trajectory
for me and and then enter drugs and
alcohol and that just you know
completely screwed me up sent me down
you know a dark path for many many years
and so I met my maker with that and was
forced to get sober but along the way
had really destroyed a lot of
relationships and Trust with a lot of
people had you know decimated my career
you know basically there was a lot of
wreckage in my path so I went from this
guy who said this guy's gonna be a
senator - you know - to dirtbag status
and then had to inch my way back to
regain that trust so even so when I got
sober and I'm being introduced to these
spiritual concepts and I'm being forced
to confront the truth of my actions and
I'm trying to connect with myself for
the very first time you when you
medicate throughout your entire
adolescence and 20s you're creating a
barrier between you and your
consciousness the entire time yeah when
you finally remove that you're this
bundle of nerves you don't know who you
are it's very confusing and disorienting
and it took many years of me trying to
figure out like Who am I what makes me
tick and during that process I still was
very attached to this idea of the
American Dream not because I had some
passion for it but it was really an
external pressure of like I need to
prove that I can that I'm not this
dirtbag that I can be this respectful
person that that that person that I was
in high school that you know I can show
my parents and everybody else that that
that's truly Who I am but that was all
[ __ ] yeah that was a law school
right and it took me a decade to
understand that for myself and to let go
of that which is terrifying
you know like let go of this idea that
you promised your entire life on for as
far back as you can remember is a sense
of freefall I'm sure it's what you you
know experienced and and and when you're
a safety seeker like I was there's
always you always know what the next
thing is gonna be like you're kind of
going from here and then this is what
you do and then this is what happens to
let go of that and have no TrueNorth or
not no sense of what that next step is
gonna be is was scarier than going to
rehab it was scarier than you know any
of the interent races that I've done
it's a sense of disorientation that is
really hard to describe thanks for being
so vulnerable or sharing that that's I
don't know if I answered your question
you'd nailed it
oh man like in spades that I love the
journey of moving from there into you
know your the physical fitness and in
finding ultra your memoir let's talk
about the plant-based diet
I think that's a huge part of what I
understand externally as something right
if I with can you give me is it a
personal philosophy is it uh is it a
health-based philosophy that all those
things some none like give me the give
me the little plan because I'm like rich
role plant-based everything and you've
got you know great merchandise and right
well you know I I would sit like rather
than slap a label on it and say this is
how I identify it's probably better to
just tell a story great and you know
that story is very wedded to you know
the story that I've been telling you
which is you know throughout my 30s
sober trying to repair my life and
establish myself is this respectful
person I had taken a lot of those
addictive alcoholic tendencies and
placed them not on fitness but on work I
was very much a workaholic and so much
so that by the time I was 39 I was 50
pounds overweight I was never like a big
mobile morbidly obese guy but I was like
a hefty heavy guy who was essentially a
couch potato like I hadn't despite the
fact that I'd been this athlete in
college I was not taking care of myself
physically I was just working and you
know subsisting on fast food and you
know shitty lifestyle habits and the
like so by the time I was 39 you know I
was kind of like a wreck physically and
that's when I was having this
existential crisis so I'm confused about
what I'm doing with my life and that
this this kind of perfect storm
percolated that in which this
existential crisis that I was having
collided with a health scare where I was
walking up a simple flight of stairs to
go to bed after a long day at work one
evening and had to pause you know I
don't want to be overly dramatic about
it but like I had tightness in my chest
and and you know as somebody who thought
of himself as an athlete to have to like
take a break walking up a flight of
stairs because you're out of breath was
like this is like thirty I'm not bad old
you know 39 you know sweat on my brow
and kind of buckle
/ and it was a symbolic moment in which
I realized that the way I was living my
life was just untenable like I needed it
was another bottom for me it was similar
to the day that I decided to get sober
I had this palpable strong sense that
once again I was having one of those
moments that if I had the awareness and
the presence of mind to really feel in
that moment could be a catalyst for
another major lifestyle change like I
was very aware of that in that moment
and I didn't know what that meant all I
knew is that I needed to jump on it and
take advantage of it right away or it
would pass like that day that I went to
rehab if I decided well maybe tomorrow
you know who knows you know what would
have happened like I I knew that there
was an urgency to it and that urgency
required some specific actions that
needed to be undertaken and for me that
translated into like I went immediately
into like this 7 day juice fast cleanse
thing not because like I felt like I
needed to I had toxins that yeah
whatever
like I just needed to do something hard
yeah you know I was like this evac'd I'd
never gone a day without eating food I
was like this this is like going to
rehab for food and lifestyle and it was
hard it was very difficult but at the
end of that seven-day period of
basically just subsisting on juice fruit
juice and vegetable juice
I had this resurgence in vitality that
was kind of amazing like I couldn't
believe that after a week of not eating
I suddenly felt better than I'd felt and
as long as I could remember and that
triggered me into this journey to try to
find a way of eating that would allow me
to feel that way all the time and that
was a messy experience of many months of
trying lots of different things but
ultimately settling into eating a plant
only diet that was the one thing that I
tried that actually allowed me to feel
vital throughout the day in a very
balanced manner you know you know in a
way that I surprised me I wasn't
expecting that
so my adoption you didn't see I wasn't
like no I'm gonna be this Vee
now like I was just trying to find a way
to feel good yeah it was very much a
selfish health oriented yeah goal eating
plants worked and so I've just been
doing that ever since
yeah when you find something that works
for ya and so it's important to me that
that people understand that I'm not
coming from this super dogmatic place
I've been doing it now for 12 years and
it still works great for me and I
promised myself that if at any point I
came to a crossroads where I wasn't
feeling good or it felt like something
was awry or a mess that I would be
intellectually honest about that and
address it and if that meant that I
needed to go and eat other types of
foods that I had to entertain that
possibility I mean that day hasn't come
yet
yeah I still feel great 52 I'm still
able to go out and kill it and what this
journey has taught me has this journey
has taught me so much like now my
interest in this lifestyle and way of
eating has expanded beyond the
parameters of just you know my waistline
and my personal sense of vitality to our
collective responsibility to care for
the well-being of our planet and all of
these sentient animals I think we can
all agree we don't treat so great
particularly in a factory farming
context and to help people kind of
better understand that and create a
connection between the foods that we're
eating and where they come from because
the whole system is erected to prevent
us from really being emotionally and
intellectually connected to that process
I think that's a but that arc is really
cool and natural and it's not like
everyone comes into a probe for their
own
reasons and on their own path yours that
moment walking up the stairs so it's
such a focused moment what about those
of us I'll put myself in this category
knock on wood
no one else cares feel good how do you
tap into a thing that you don't even
know you're missing yeah I mean that's
like that's the secret sauce right there
and again I wish I had a pithy answer
for that because for me pains really
been feeling like yeah when I'm in
enough pain like then I can move the
needle and I can make the changes right
and the big changes that I've made in my
life have been a result of being in a
tremendous amount of pain but let's
square that with the understanding and
the realization that those changes and
those choices are always available to us
we need not suffer in order to avail
ourselves of what they have to offer so
how can we make the choice without the
suffering right yeah it's like I don't
know that's hard yeah like who does that
you know what I mean Tim Ferriss right
yeah I guess a certain certain alien
humans are able to do that
but I think it's about it's about it
goes back to that mind body soul
connection it's about being present with
who you are and I think meditation is
really the superpower skill that can
create a sense of awareness to be in a
situation to make that choice yeah you
know because I think we're all visited
with like whether it's the moment I
decided to go to rehab or that line in
the sand moment of like I'm changing my
like who would have thought that a
staircase episode and a decision to like
change my diet would deliver me to
sitting next to you to do this it's like
it's insane right you can't imagine or
predict these things but I think that
we're all visited with these moments and
if you're paying attention if you're
present with yourself you're more likely
to be aware when they are when they
descend upon
as opposed to blindly reacting to your
environment and just bumping up against
what was happening you know and then
missing the gift and allowing it to pass
yeah that awareness self awareness
mindfulness meditation that whole space
has been transformational for me
personally I think it's as you said
earlier I think you described it as a
vehicle or a path or a grounding element
to be able to be attuned to till it
stops right well I think a better yeah
agreed and I think maybe a more concrete
way of putting it is if you're on the
wrong path for yourself the universe is
gonna let you know it's gonna knock
softly at first and if you're not
listening and it's gonna start to knock
louder and louder and louder and if you
continue to not pay attention to not
have the wherewithal or the mindfulness
to course-correct then you're gonna end
up in a car crash you know some metaphor
achill one like there's gonna be some
you know situation that arises or
Cataclysm that is going to force you to
finally confront this thing that you're
you know refusing to look at so the
question becomes like can you
course-correct when the knock is gentle
and again it goes back to being aware or
aware you are the more present the more
mindful you are of your surroundings in
yourself the more likely you're going to
be to be able to take notice can I ask a
couple more questions about the
plant-based diet sure what about blood
type stuff the you know is that shaky
science or I'll just I'm not a doctor
I'm not a nutritionist and I'm not a
scientist and I don't play one on the
internet but I will tell you that I'm
Type O which yeah and what I understand
is the is the type that they supposed to
keep beat yeah I had no I had never
heard this I find myself craving protein
and when I have protein animal-based
protein I feel better
and again this is BS I called you I have
not I've done some plant-based only for
some time or I haven't done like the
Master Cleanse or anything that right
I'm small small versions
I'm intrigued by the footprint on the
planet I'm interning by just balance and
doing what's right but also I can't get
out of the cycle of like yeah craving
hardcore dose of protein so cravings are
are unreliable narrators though at times
I mean there is undoubtedly a connection
between the quality of your microbiome
and the signals that are being sent to
your brain that get translated into
cravings so sometimes that craving is
real it's because your body really does
need something and sometimes it's
because your microbiome is saying this
is what we like or it is just some you
know habit that gets triggered where
you're uncomfortable not saving it in
that way and I think to really
understand the difference
you have to whether those cravings for a
period of time whether it's 30 days or
something like that to see how
legitimate they really are and you know
only you know and everybody's different
on the first person to say like look I
can only speak from my own experience
you know I'm sharing from a place of you
know personal experience working for me
yeah right so tell me a little bit about
the cookbook so I want people to be able
to find find them on the internet yeah
so in the wake of writing finding ultra
and telling my story it seemed natural
that the next book ought to be about
food because food plays such a big role
in my own personal evolution and what
I've been able to do athletically and
people were interested and how that
works so we wrote a cookbook called the
plant power way which is very
family-friendly introductory primer to
eating a plant-based diet with recipes
that are super traditional like potato
salad and lasagna like it's there's this
sense that if you're eating a
plant-based diet you're gonna be
crawling around in your yard like you
know chewing grass out of it you know
like or just eating salad and celery
and that's certainly not the way that I
eat like I'm you know Hardy I push my
body like I'm very physically active and
I have a huge appetite I need a lot of
food and I want to feel like those
what I'm putting in my in my mouth is
gonna stick to my ribs so this book is
sort of intended to serve that and my
wife is incredible cook they're all her
recipes and and we wrote another
cookbook called the plant power way
Italia we do these retreats in the
Italian countryside every year we take
groups of 30 to 40 people through a
seven-day experience that involves
meditation and trail running and
mindfulness and a lot of you know
intense workshops but of course also
food and collaborating with the chefs
of that region produced this amazing
cookbook that is a plant-based spin on
your favorite Italian recipes best place
for people to find and track you down on
the internet easy to find just you can
google my name is rich Rolle calm is my
website everything goes on the podcast
it's just the rich roll podcast wherever
you listen to find podcasts and they're
available on YouTube as well amazing so
yeah as this thank you so much for being
a guest on my podcast think speaking of
podcast and I'm looking forward to being
on your they've already agreed it's
happening yeah cool thank you so much
for sharing your story the insights the
vision it's incredibly inspiring yeah
and I got work to do but I can tell you
it is an honor to meet you and be on
your show as a longtime fan of
everything that you do and put out into
the world with with the highest degree
of integrity uh it's been a pleasure man
thank you so much and forever it out
there listening
check out rich of stuff everywhere on
the internet and thank you for tuning in
and hopefully see you hear from you
you'll see me or whatever on the
Internet
you